welcome to video playing yahoo door JA
door um from netherlands we got a king's
gambit should I play g5 oh come on i do
it I don't really know it in any detail
but yeah it's fun for some side came he
played Knight c3 this is one of those
some newer approaches I think to the
opening where white is very often
playing a quick g3 yeah i just bought
stir this chain yeah and now he played
it very very murky sorry very murky
position hard too hard to understand and
and play I wonder should I just go for
long castles maybe I can prepare long
castling knight c6 Bishop d7 and he's
not going to quickly make me on f7 or
anything I don't don't think that this
is happening a problem though is 27 for
example is met by 95 hmm is he going to
play e5 maybe let's let's play a small
improving move that okay yeah he's
aiming his his guns at f7 mm-hmm should
I castling short and maybe I can cancel
short simply night on g4 some doing a
good job here but I don't really know
maybe just King evade what I'm trying to
do is maybe 95
yeah this is the problem the whole thing
is totally confusing even if maybe i'm
not saying black it's much better even
if black should be much better it's
still it's still totally confusing okay
so at least them he's not beating around
the bush yeah I really don't see how I
can not take it so you will take or he
would take on d6 otherwise i'll just
take the pond uh huh interesting you
will play what to do six if i go to e7
maybe
notta not much choice really okay d 6 on
second one g5 can also be that each one
to ones to second g5 okay I prepare 96
here anyway 96 and 27 long castling
layer okay yeah I don't really mind so
much that it maybe take cm how crazy is
a divide if i play move like f 6 cm just
trying to try to hold the whole
structure I really wanted to take Bishop
takes but I don't want to lose lose the
whole whole position or f5f why is this
f5s is very open right but maybe it
forces things come on let's play a fiver
i don't i don't know maybe you can take
on f8 and after this now can can can
somehow sacrifice on g5 on if if i get
in 96 and let's say if he has no
sacrifice right now i think after 96 i
will be very much okay and he must do
something like that som some slow movers
probably not on at all but i have i have
this year with the tempo let's say queen
queen to f6 and long castling
yeah that's the Kings gambit for you you
you actually close to opening the
champagne bottle sir just when you get
your king out of the middle what a
strange opening allow for maybe maybe I
can go if 4e for III taking the night
maybe cannot cannot spend hours on this
I'm not sure about them it can also just
play Bishop e2 another thing that i have
is Bishop to h6 out basically thread
basically forcing him to two sec the
exchange I'm not sure if this is any
good maybe maybe maybe e-forms really
not good young if you can take here
takes takes bishop h5 check team is
seven but it's there is something yeah
come on I need to I need to I need to
play cannot i will not figure this out
in one minute 50 and maybe you can play
rook age five actually why didn't i play
you three it's the same thing i can just
take the night then wow I could is the
lady three this was the idea after all
about okay okay take here okay Bishop f7
a day well don't tell me this is still
compensation this should be really good
for black now okay and just just get the
King out of this
takes a five I will cast along on move
26 check um okay check okay my king is
not so bad here after the pawn capture I
can do eight this is a fairly check
fairly safe King position want to go to
e5 and then I'm then I'm coordinated f6
I can go back to the AIDS wait wait wait
wait just a moment now maybe attack the
Bashar time warning
check I really should win the bishop now
come on white reasons poor Sophie it's
always a wide wired right boom yeah and
I missed a ton of things probably yeah
yeah let's let's start around here I
mean even the most before certainly I've
warrant an examination but who came I
played rukka fade and this this is of
course a very brutal approach but ok
it's the Kings gambit and now yeah in
the computer stockfish wants to play
Bishop b5 now this makes some sense
certainly trying to exchange the
defender of them c4 bond Jack it wasn't
really sure about all this but I have
Roo KTM I have a gay too this is the
main thing now ok yeah def 5 but 5 at
least at the moment the computer does
not see a win for white which is
reassuring d success what the compass
now it sees a win at F takes g5 this is
what he played and this is not working
like an F to G five is the win
or at least better for white and
witnesses maybe too much I really don't
understand that here is going Bishop e2
winning yeah this is maybe just two
began on the checkya this is Jack not
working yeah great the tech yeah well as
I said there is a sacrifice right now
and his winning or probably if there is
no direct sacrifice is losing and this
is the sacrifice that at least according
to the engine here is not supposed to
work now just Queenie seven is so good
yeah okay this is also good and now III
I mean I'm just an idiot yeah why didn't
I just play III this was what I had
planned with e for just III with a tempo
he cannot do anything and then I take g5
and over very weird yeah this one and
this isn't isn't isn't really clear
right I mean I'm a piece up but who well
this seems to be winning again so what
is a drug h1m yeah this is not clear
really not I mean there is all kinds of
weird attacking moves song 96 for
example poor and maybe this is a spot
where I should return a piece if we look
at this for example if I just let him
take on f7 I still have a pawn who yeah
tough but good here there is really
nothing right check check yeah this is
what once was a convincing way to
convert yeah this opening is always
always world okay thanks for watching